AND UNDER WAY FROM ENTER TRYINGT
THROUGH TRAFFIC BUT GOT HIS
RIGHT ELBOW ON WAY BACK DEFENSER
SUNDQVIST.
>> John: OFF THE FACE-OFF
WHIPPED IN BY THE CORNER.
AND NOW LOGAN BROWN FIGHTS OFFGD
FIRM PASSED AT THE POINT AND
>> John: ISVERBERG SHOOTS IT TIS
OUT HIGH NOW
GOALTENDER BUT WITH THAT PLAY TO
KEEP PUCK AND WAS THE FLIP CAN Y
FANCY OVER THE SHOULDER AND
AROUND
WITH THAT COMPOSURE FROM BEHIND
THE NET TO FLIP IT THE MIDDL
WHISTLE.
OUT.G TO CENTER
ONE AND THEN TROY FATIGUE
LEGS TO PUSH THE OPPOSITION,
SUNDQVIST THERE, BUT IT'S
>> Darren: NATHAN WALKER HAD
EVERY RIGHT TO FIRE THIS PUCK AS
A LEFTY IN NOW LUNDESTROM
BACK IN THEM.
>> Darren: A BRILLIANT SAVED
TO KEEP THIS A 1-1IS AS A PLAYEE
PLAY, HEHE
STOLARZ
MANSON FOR
HE TAKES ADVANTAGE OF THIS GREAT
MOVE BY FOWLER AND GO.
>> Darren: TERRIFIC STRENGTH
ON THE PUCK
GUARANTEEING EACHEFT IN
TROY TERRY, WHAT A BREAKOUT YEAR
FOR THAT YOUNG MAN PEERE IN BENT
SHOT DOES NOT HERE.
MUST MAKE THE SAVE TO KEEP IT